o parte de las celebraciones del día de
muertos en el palacio nacional se
instalaron altares y tapetes de flores
monumentales que elaboraban
representantes de 20 pueblos indígenas
de méxico este sábado al presidente de
lópez obrador le practicaron un ritual
de limpia con humo de copal según la
tradición mazateca y este domingo
también se llevan a cabo ceremonias de
pueblos originarios como el huichol de
nayarit o en agua de puebla en la zona
chinampera de xochimilco al sur de la
ciudad se presenta el espectáculo de la
llorona los visitantes recorren en
trajineras los canales del lago que son
escenarios de música en vivo teatro y
danza mexica una de las tradiciones más
vivas del día de muertos es la
instalación de ofrendas para los seres
queridos que se han ido son altares que
se decoran con la típica flor de
cempasúchil papel picado veladoras y la
comida y bebida que solía disfrutar el
difunto el fondo mixto de promoción
turística organizó un concurso en
instagram con el hashtag ofrenda
infinita para que la gente suba las
fotos de sus ofrendas y se hará una
selección para que las mejores sean
exhibidas en espacios públicos de la
capital y en sedes consulares de méxico
en estados
otra tradición imperdible es el consumo
de pan de muerto hoy en día los hay
rellenos de chocolate o de jalea o
incluso pan de muerto vegano o libre de
gluten la secretaria de turismo local y
la industria restaurantera harán un
reconocimiento y selección mediante
votación virtual de los mejores panes de
muerto de entre 100 panaderías
tradicionales de la ciudad